Alexa be quiet dishwasher be quiet
dishwasher doesn't listen to me I
started it about an hour ago so
hopefully it finishes at some point
before the entire stream ends I'm back
for arena Kings season five week nine
Monday November November 11th November
11th 6:58 p.m. Central time in st. Louis
this is going to be a two-hour long
event starts in less than 90 seconds 53
players it's just 960 Fisher random I
was gonna prepare but at least in terms
of opening preparation it's hard to
prepare spoke so specifically maybe I
should have done some like some tactics
beforehand I prepared by cooking eggs
and I bought I bought lions baby powder
which is supposed to improve memory and
focus so we'll see if it works
I could play Hans Neiman in the first
round or master Zachary probably not
been Feingold but we'll see yeah a
second okay playing master Zachary
played this person many times before
whoa so the bishops and lights just
switched places and the king and queen
switch places to know what to do okay
this is reasonable hmm I'm gonna be
aggressive and go for a 4 KB chooses
slight weakness
and they c5 Knight a5 threatening nasty
things I'll play this move defending
it's already like kind of complicated
position I might play b6 at some point
Wow play f6 unleash this bishop defend
the pawn there's some ideas of this
check eventually and I mean literally
that happened stock this welcome back
shoutouts off this let's take this thing
mm-hmm
they're they're not sure good like b6 o
maybe not a great move you take with
rook huh 96 is coming their night B
sevens coming mm-hmm yeah I got tricked
thinking about sacking in exchange I
think I will
I'm gonna go for this check down the
volume to expecting Bishop takes e5 and
I'll just take back with the rook I'll
have a little bit of initiative against
b2 opponent thinking yeah let's go for
this it's interesting
hey it's a raid Peter Bachus thanks for
rating shout out to Peter a new chest
streamer let's play this move well
there's Queenie Chuck we need for king
c8 then I can take
could leave some tension leave some
tension if Queen here I played g5o
queenside castling sneaky let's play
this move
maybe I'll Kings like a soul at the King
to g8 rook ty fates
but then I probably don't to play g5
hello to the Chilean viewer is their
increment I don't think there's any
increment okay I could take now this is
just three minutes they'll play this
move Queen age six ideas a force hanging
yeah not my proudest position this pawn
is also hanging I could take the Knights
and play this move play 96 perhaps you
Knight a six drops a piece what am i
doing I can't even go like in castle
latex so bad oh let's do I'm gonna
resign very soon I just want to try a
few more potential tricks like this is a
trick woo it paid off or did it I'm
getting mated I'm getting needed that's
so sad resign
okay next king what a bad start i sacked
a piece I did with my opponents Queen
though some consolation my coaster is
stuck to my tea it might be a sign ooh
okay playing lower rated opponents
whenever a rook is behind the center
pawn usually it's good it's a good pawn
to move okay making my Bishop happy
let's make them knight happy it's all
about making pieces happy let's take
this improve the night
let's play this move being catalyst
Bishop hmm I'd like to attack
maybe this move mmm why this move
preparing d4
at 75 ideas
d5 not sure it's just Castle rooks our
happy little block plays d5 always play
King b1 ok pawns are very happy like a
three a slow hopefully methodical build
up at six
like Queen h3 and tickle the pawn and
keep keep pressuring the pawns okay so
no more pressure on my pawns and
pressure against g6 I might be winning
the pond I mean there's rook g8 or that
move play this move
I'm just gonna try and play quickly keep
applying pressure upon this plane
decently let's play play this move I'm
only get to f4 and target d5 in h5o but
well if I can do that there's some pin
happening
I play rook f1 first yeah hello two more
people in the chat Leon Dyke peppermint
biscuits everyone else taggi alright so
I got out of the pin now neither for
coming next
maybe this yeah the night has various
adventures it can it can take
very direct flight to c5 and when upon I
could but no need I'll put the other
night on f4
now very positional gay maybe the bishop
will come back hit the rook a floor can
be played I saved my queen now left for
his week its attacked four times
potentially five times let's take a pawn
oh that was hanging I I'd be tricky hmm
let's take another pawn so my Queens
aligned with the night which means I
might have some discoveries the Queen's
attacked has to move somewhere it's
reasonable that's a confusing position
let's play this move
and I'm probably just gonna win on time
well let's take this thing
lots of trades I'm only up a pawn in the
end but that should be enough
combined with the time my knight found
happiness and bishops unleashed hmm look
the rook behind the pawn and then push
the other pass pawn this is a nice move
nope I lost upon that opponent in
tickets
I'll take this
okay solid game
so had a rough first game starts but
trying to recover Oh what to do let's
push spawn and yeah lights developing
look pretty reasonable just copying my
opponent hey the first bits of today
thank you you got Jess I can't play a
Kings Indian attack because it's
chess960 but maybe I'll I'll try and
invent something something similar
appreciate the bits good to see you back
I think I want the Castle kingside
I have to clear the the pieces let's put
the Bishop on b7 throw-in each six
probably put my knight on e5 okay 95
miss bishop ooh it's developed edition
and develop it even more some eg-6 ideas
it's kind of annoying let's play this I
think I'm okay with a bishop trade oh I
might lose g7 but I'll have some
initiative like takes takes takes g7 g8
like a four whoa a far far far far oh my
gosh I'm losing more pawns the
distraction bits in two thousand of them
thanks so much a far far far far I have
this move I have this move its way this
move first hit the Knights most of my
next several moves will come with
threats and this attacks a queen this
will attack the knight this will attack
mates mmm this is tricky they call
attack tonight I'm offering basically a
trade ooh what is this where does my
Queen go I can take a pawn lose a bishop
win tonight okay so I'm still attacking
the knight i won a pawn back I'm still
down upon that materials not so relevant
when pieces are just dying everywhere
and I'd still attacked 94 expected maybe
and then I could could check
my queen f4 looks most reasonable I
could take upon so now materials equal
but it's still just crazy my castle
what was the starting position yeah I
can castle if I want but I can't castle
I can't castle yet because bishops
controlling CAS castling look at my King
on see a truck NDA's if this I can take
I think takes
well maybe it's complicated Bishop e2
okay well there's c5 there's rook a five
you're okay five looks Pleasant just
defending the knight activating the rook
hmm what next to do and y'all put this
rook back just guard the back rank oh
that's a heat I have to turn off the
heat
because the place is already pretty warm
be right back okay I'm back I could take
the Queen oh I could take the Queen and
trade everything I think I'll do that
okay oh this is nice
do this so it's still equal material but
I have active rook hmm let's activate
the King
activate the knight next
hmm
and 95.6 just defend
of c3 Knight b3 y'all do this move just
apply pressure check c5 coming next
g4 trick g1 block hit on f7 I think okay
let's go back and defend and take a pawn
what does a knight doing let's attack
the Knights I'm gonna try and trap the
night lights
officially trapped almost worked g2
possible but then I'll play Knight g5
cutting off the defense I'm winning the
Knights okay that was nice finish the
toxic banana is back I ate a banana
today it wasn't so toxic what is this
position mites okay start with this move
maybe wait d5 it's just about the
Knights two reasonable squares and now d
5r e 5 maybe needless move D 5 and then
F 6 there's no F 4 get some sort of like
French structure
yeah I'm pleased with this plate you six
I think I've kind of decided that I'm
happier with more positional games
rather than like crazy tactics I like
when the structure is more static
because then it's pretty clear like
where the pieces should go like here
this is my my general plan
maybe h6 g5 someday King is relatively
safe toxic Inanna
I'm sorry baby but this is Fisher random
so I'll have to get really lucky and get
a normal chest position chest starting
position to have any chance of time AMA
but we'll see maybe your bits will
provide some good home in what to do
here maybe this move it looks passive
but things are solid might do this move
soon maybe eventually this move okay
fair enough play Bishop efore I have
also see c5 you know there yada let's
play c5 it's a little bit double-edged
well I take the knight takes
give the treat but that doesn't quite
work oh that's a good move play this
takes I think I'll take and if takes
Bishop h5 hitting the rook and Knight e
- probably expected Bishop e2 another
reasonable move should probably take and
then d4
that piece is not so happy I liked my
position earlier unless scary things
were happening this is still reasonable
maybe I'll do this this just my king is
feeling some heat as this moves coming
so I have Bishop d6 I have a nice time
and managed to just have to weather the
storm a little bit I mean the rook will
come here and then I'll castle
or maybe even this castling will put the
King on c8 should be fine
so I defend the bishop
these pawns are still kind of terrifying
whoo and now the night is terrifying
I couldn't move move this way I have the
C file to work with oh man
Oh what to do takes takes my Queen Queen
uh fades it's kind of a fork attacking
this and this and then if I take this
all the attacking this about 94 I 94
it's quite strong but maybe opponent
doesn't see it maybe four probably can
be eight no just try and survive
yes and I still want to take I think
that's probably a good move hmm I'm just
going to play it safe
what to do
maybe the smooth
I have a trick in mind maybe this move
was my trick threatening meats and more
importantly provoking my opponent to
think take sticks there there mmm
actually that should be okay
take with King actually this ending is
is reasonable
thank you okay no I think the ending was
actually quite fine Oh master Zachary
let's try and get some revenge he beat
me the first game a sneaky move
attacking that pawn I saw it
oh let's attack this pawn so yeah the
first game I have just got outplayed
tactically in the opening weird move but
try and make it work
if this 94 I can always castle its
castle I want to play f4 f5
hmm completely five can also play maybe
a 592 also a move 92 is probably safest
I think I'll play Bishop III Queen c1 if
I have the time
this night's so depressing let's play
this move just blunder upon I could
probably train and when d5 and end if I
get the chance I'll play d3 or e5 hmm so
I could take first
yeah let's trade everything I cover d4
so there's no Queen d4 check and then
I'll take with Queen yeah this looks
very reasonable because the Knights
still out of play Bishop is also kind of
out of play F sevens of targets Queen
moves there Wow Queen e7 and so much
activity three attackers against f7 if
Queen here I just take the f7 can't be
defended unless I can I can take to take
with um with rook even stick with the
rook takes Queen go for this I'll bring
my knight back I'm bishop actually like
nicely restricts the Knights cyanide
welcome I'm not really looking too much
at the check I believe this move as
Queen D 6 so let's prevent Queen d6
first Queen's tied down to the back ring
I do want to do this very soon
okay
oh there's Queen uh for preventing my
threats so maybe 96
yeah 92 I can just take it to do have
this move as if takes I'm eight takes
Queenie eight and meanwhile I attack the
Knights there should be seven I take
ticks and mates Knights stock if here I
meet it was there oh well there's a nice
move does it work oh it almost works
bishop g8 so close to working but then
Queen takes doesn't quite work maybe
just a smooth yeah solid move the
night's almost trapped that's tricky
let's play this move it's not a lot of
time there
the Knights still almost trapped I have
this threat might be five queenie 7
should be game over the queen f4 so
resourceful i have this move oh wow
it doesn't quite work
have to go for this
on the verge of winning but now it's
it's me tricky with the time situation
opponent thinking though to watch out
for like Queen uh one meat and the end
of some lines so I'll probably throw in
h3 when I got the chance in King f8 No
okay guess not let's play this move
expecting vision takes T three then I'll
play h3 even night of six no six is nice
hmm kind of going for the trade
it's all about time
my queen with check that will be nice
flag what's going on some lag at the end
there okay I pulled through I feel like
I should have been winning maybe people
in the chat found a quicker way for me
to win playing Indian lad um let's play
b3i let's move
it's a weird way to develop the queen
but looks reasonable play this move put
the palm in III restrict the Knights
bishops are happy now hmm no Castle g4
here should be okay Bishop c7 F for I
think this pawn is pinned uh no um
Poisson no structure looks reasonable b5
interesting move there's g3 let's play
d3 pawns are smiling play this move
scary but trying to whether the the pawn
storm
happy to trade Queen uh 6mm tricky hmm I
always play Nike one okay
pawns are still smiling feeling some
pressure though yeah feeling a lot of
pressure of this moan this move allows
Mike to come in might have to do it
though I mean what else feel stuck
yeah my goal is to call off the Queen
[Music]
yes I have this move and this move -
very ugly position let's try this
I'll play Knight b5 how's a good move
[Music]
I'm getting smashed here this is so ugly
my bishop do you one just trying to
trade just have to trade more things a
little good move take six get away with
us oh no I can't
it's 92 check nasty oh so nasty resigned
well played
yeah my king was not bad a very bad
place okay next opponent I've lost two
games I'm still top 20 hmm I have
something like normal chests let's
control the center let's get pawns in
the center bishop developing all about
finding happiness
a g5 whoo hey smooth okay looks fun to
attack here the goal is to play H 5 H 4
and this pawns nice now yeah I want to
play just H 4 yeah that's a move I could
take you'll start with this takes I take
with Knights and that's what I was
waiting for it's now it should be easier
to finish off the attack
turning meets Ritchie one expected keep
pushing pawns oh there's a nice trick
oh there's very nice trick Bishop Bishop
e5 is a threat because of the pin mmm c3
it's a fork
the other queen moves sideways too
yeah this is just about over oh there's
Richie - okay let's play a five you know
I'm up a piece life is very good so I
have 13 Tournament points close to top
10 lady 3
just have to make sure I'm still
defending this let's get the other rook
in uh-oh I just plunder I think I just
plundered a big-time opponent had a
knight takes g5 because if Bishop takes
I would get me that my queen would be
trapped that was close the okay the
queen is kind of stuck but I can't
really be attacked
you know where's a breakthrough maybe
each three at some point I have to
attack from all directions a threat is
this and this or this
okay next game whoo playing high very
high rated player from Russia right
Russia yeah to be careful and not a
title player
okay I just want to have a solid
position as solid as possible on some
idea of this and this develop the queen
queen is not happy both queens not happy
in this position passed upon 99 welcome
back 9999 yeah so my problem is if I do
this so it's Bishop c2 so I might just
have to deal with Bishop e4 play this
move okay
reasonable positional game oh the bishop
is getting stuck
if f5 passed ball 99 thanks for subbing
of 5 only move really it's kind of nasty
nasty but necessary this move
oh but then things are happening play
this move first and then e 5
okay this is still playable I'm Bishop
c4 King h8 have a slight time advantage
white screen kind of stuck this bishops
um knowing mr. 5:5 Queen g8 or g6 before
is hanging yeah I had to do that after
three
I played g6 almost but not quite rookie
three
I love Queen defends I can take it in
Bishop c5 oh and I'm bishop moves back I
take okay so some initiative start with
checking hmm think I'll take Queen g8
and so there's some pressure here White
has two bishops but I have better pieces
play rook team one also Queen d4 it's
kind of interesting let's play rook do
you one first
we should be - I have rook D to Bishop
III here as I wanna play riff D - so
trying to like trap the bishop basically
also my king is kind of trapped - be
careful
I don't think I'm through all right
maybe I am threatening to take 7 IG 8 oh
wow what does this take
Quinn eh five problems let's play this
finding Queen G one kind of Queen g3 oh
wow
I've worked d2 I'm in trouble now
I've Queen d7 Queen d7 I think saves me
[Music]
hmm
oh dear
what's going on
so terrifying
Wow
I know oh wow really there's a win there
yes
the dirty flag but got the job done like
before man intense game oh I'll play c4
c4 Bishop C 2 a 3
and d3 and d4 is coming a close position
if it takes I'll take back with the pawn
I'm gonna put the bishop
yeah bishop putting putting the bishop
on a diagonal that matters let's play
this move g4 night it's not each two
should maybe Castle queenside
hmm
what to do
there's some f3 move my Castle kingside
actually I'm depending what happens
takes takes by Bishop g5 first a4 as a
possible move but then I can take
I'm actually quite pleased with this
Guinea to delayed bond cloud I want to
play this move the king is very safe
and a big fight for the ifile coming up
but for now the Knights kind of
restricted my eight-six I have rigged up
6 play this move ooh a file is open I
was expecting a 5 there
ok let's fight for the e-file maybe take
on g4
hmm
not entirely sure looks like it could
maybe somehow work yeah let's take we
should be to my box still pretty
restricted
I can't resist bishops are are gonna be
very happy here
but now let's
now what play who
play this move i sacked a piece but and
there's still some cop
it takes takes we got six
okay double attack this defends
everything that forgets about to be to
pawn or be six pawn a knight of seven
also a move - seven well
the attacks h5 -
I have a trap I play this rook takes h5
I can check in win the rook still
setting up the trap also attacking the
Knights
yeah this is very pleasant Queen h5 not
happening
hmm
what to do here
it should be very close to winning each
seven coming yeah my nights just
completely out of play these bishops
also very much out of play right is this
hey G tag thanks for subbing somehow I
missed it
just by J welcome back oh I'm playing
chess weebs joss whedon be dangerous
sometimes let's play let's play C 4 V 4
maybe T 4 at some point like Queen c2
and just defend let's develop the knight
I should be - yeah that's reasonable
hopefully 3 just by 5 probably coming or
that move I can take 94
maybe queenside castling at some points
like right now looks a little bit shaky
ff3 mm Windex before i'm c-54 then 95
it's quite up 3
it's dangerous pan to take opponent exit
what to do
c5c 595 a3 queen a for its interesting
position at the very least
mom
so I have a three here
I honestly don't see where the Queen's
moving so free Queen it's not an idea
for took away the only Queen move okay
tough game
I I thought I was just gonna get smashed
if black played 95 rather than Knights a
four
all right let's play Knight b3 and
honorary of Knight be free and I'll push
Center pawns
okay I just want to make pieces happy
this [ __ ] can develop maybe here I'm not
at that square
play off three
I don't like this move is tricky the
pawns pinned to the rook by the bishop
oh the opponent's doing the same thing I
can have this move a problem is just
copying me while this move no okay
so no more copying I've c4 c4 is
playable
weird game this move - I can castle now
oh I can't do that hmm
I could just do this what did you
provoke g6
hmm
now let's do this first let's pause
hanging
but okay now I get some file I'll get
some initiative to have this move was g6
well there's interesting line let's go
for this g6 97 maybe you have a fork in
blacks territory ideas of this something
there's rook e8 very strange situation
d6 I can not really want to take I have
95 maybe just sac apiece
hmm
Oh what to do
difficult situation
I think I'll do this so I want to keep
white screen or black screen restricted
I'd even take oh I'm gonna do Pullman
doesn't take the free piece as I was
gonna take plate 5 and go over Queen g6
I might still have the same idea yeah
let's do it
can pre-movie 5 i'm just stacking all
the pawns to open the whole center
that's probably okay this is nice
attacking g6 and the bishop i think i
was like in trouble at some points but
now things are coming to life it still
takes a bit of work but yeah the rooks
won't be connected how can i take
probably not should play king h1 safety
first
whoa Joana try is rating with a party of
36
thanks so much show Ana and shout-out to
Joanna I was watching christiane earlier
okay I do have to focus
Oh to do Queenie eights coming we need
okay so I'll take first this work we
need a truck takes f6 I wouldn't h8 in
the end you think it works
yeah then I'll trade everything it's
good enough
okay beautiful let's take check and
let's not flag
mmm tricky
huh
and 17 seconds should be plenty of time
okay beautiful yeah shoutouts s Oh
Joanna tries thanks so much for the raid
inserts pumpkin you vote okay oh I'm
playing boo car uh what to do
it's my de for Sicilian interesting
let's not lose h2c for perhaps I won't
play d4 soon 95 Wow
play this move except the double pawns
d4 I guess I'll book the Queen on d3
whoa fancy and still Queen d3 aligns
with the king
I'll probably Castle kingside
I mean yeah I'm more developed there's a
five
there's taking it's also taking this way
I'm not sure
start with castling now e5 unleashing
the battery because I have a bishop on
b1 I didn't see that until right after I
play d5 that's so sweet
let's take and OH what is this - take
care
let's not lose anything okay so I'm up a
piece let's just improve the position of
f4 is playable play this move I'm keen
eh one rook g1 coming to play f3 a solid
move
wanna play Brooke g4 Queenie driving out
of four drops of Queen a same thing with
Queen age 394 so a few potential Queen
traps of Queen e7 Queen h6 so
everything's winning I think by the for
just double-checking anything better
this is good no it's gonna take and take
on day four I have this fancy move but
then Bishop takes e5
flavor to you one let's play each for
actually Luke for the king this move a
little bit uncomfortable but I do have a
just queen for rook the lock has two
bishops let's play each five first they
tried first how did you play this move
that's gonna take a lot of work
Bishop d5 is a v4r actually check first
I have this idea to or no one doesn't
work Bishop d5 Jack let's play this
first ie yyy I know
oh there goes my advantage
please just so loud and I takes h1 not
happening though it takes f1 what Oh
tricky doesn't it work it's so sad
doing so well
okay really all the terrible terrible
thing I won the Queen it's such a great
position to opponent fought well okay so
I'm still kind of high up let's play d4
I'll play a London this game this
position is perfect for London opening
mmm take the bishop play Bishop d3 and
Queenie to Castle kingside yeah this is
like bread and butter
opening play Brooke t1 or rook am
walking um yeah that was a slight mouse
soup but it's okay maybe the rook
belongs here anyway okay so now f3 g4 I
mean all of these I think the whole game
is all like thematic London ideas you
thought I didn't like the London aim
anymore
where'd you get that false information
from I love the London it's just hard to
play in chess960 okay sneaky me threats
have five okay this is a fork also it's
removal of the garden and it's defending
this to one of the monster knights and
Queen takes expected like another free
piece another free piece okay
impressive my opponent resigned before I
could take the Queen so we have what is
this place a sealian play a dragon
dragon looks reasonable all free pawn
but also free pawn I should take out for
mmm overextending and defending
attacking like d6 I don't care about b7
I care about winning d2 threatening c4
here hmm
play h5 and maybe develop the bishop
here let's play this move
I have this idea to to try and win B -
well what is this what is this you take
its way 9a for first those night
combines well with a Bishop Knight c4
okay
like Queen twenty-seven stopping Bishop
c6 and attacking the bishop takes takes
let's play 94 first
see three expected night p3m hmm I'd
like if I could take two that it's close
to working I'm so close to working start
with this like f5 unleash this bishop
wow castling no way that's good but why
it still take let's take here first and
then do this yeah this is game over or
is it all those Bishop d5 and I'm
winning a piece I win more quickly I'll
just win a piece
yeah this is completely winning it's the
best approach are there so I'll do this
first or no I'll do this first
there's queen each eight ideas I can
take check
mommy go move yeah okay so I'll have to
deal with some checks if I'm up at night
Queeny seven trying to figure out if I
should trade Queens maybe not
Wow all right let's start with check
yeah Queen takes a seven is one check
not played I'll just walk around
let's pass pong okay next game still top
ten playing vu car again has to be
careful lady five have six I guess
aggressive I take let's develop
g5
hmm Castle queenside I maybe I'll take
complete d5 also pony prevents it hmm
yeah good move it takes takes a g5
immediately I think I should take and
like d6 just accept a worse position
bring my knight in interesting thing I
want to play e5
Bishop c4 anthem of the rook
good move what to do
thread is h5 I can play this move
training this
hmmm this move now that hangs a piece
hangs exchanged maybe I'll do it though
mmm anything better
it's uncomfortable
h 5 h 5 maybe
let me try h 5 I want my queen to come
in
problem is king c2 even Queen c3 I'll
start with this move wait I'm done the
bishop oh I lost a bishop oh that's
unfortunate
I'm trying to be inspired by my opponent
not resigning from that previous game
takes takes have to try this and I
resigned very soon though
there could be one play this would be
five oh dear
have to
takes and then I have scale matrix okay
I resign had to set up the last L matrix
okay still number twelve
okay critical game play this move attack
the pond if this and maybe be five
attack the Knights get some early
initiative mmm the f6 always play off
six okay I want to play this move next
I'm pretty pleased with opening they're
waiting for Halloween gambits not sure
if that will happen this tournament it's
hard to play even like weird openings in
in 960 or weird like normal chess
openings I don't know what I'm saying
Queen side castle yeah just get the rook
to the open file I'm sure it's possible
to play like something that resembles a
Halloween like sack apiece for Center
clones but Halloween has passed and
before coming
hmm
Oh to do a five it's all play a five
give the Queen some room whoo that's
slightly unexpected I have some pressure
some idea and I left for pitchy to
prepare this custards g3 g4 let's play
this I'm slowly activating some ideas of
this maybe cuz this this and I can take
Bishop III looks so natural
yeah now I win a piece the bishop was
defendant on g1 but not on e3 let's play
let's play Bishop c5 I'll move the
knight back nice outpost square rook t5
a trick t5 1993 rook d4 we're now 7 e7
checking b7
I think everything's ok might be playing
outs you might come in h7 and Vikings
finding safety
that's all playing out
I just want to go for the tack like the
Queen's out of play I could throw in g5
if I wanted play this move pressure now
this move I hear I can take also maybe
oh maybe I'll play 95 cutting off the
Queen let's take first
I still wanna play 95 things are really
stuck for whites like they'd see what
I'm eight hmm huh 95 is good enough I
just had to be careful Queen was
defending can be 7 and Celtic
King has to step into a discovery your
next game playing vu car again what is
this
I guess because like we already played
once where we're ending our games at the
same time so it's just pairing us okay
I'll try and get revenge again or yeah
I'll try again to get revenge no
guarantee that I will okay mmm play this
move and try and confuse them cuz I'll
have some nice interesting pawn
structure
III this is what I want just something
solid to move quickly to I'll probably
Castle kingside and then go for this
sort of stuff hmm like Queenie for this
idea FC one before
maybe rook c5 come in
in Queen B 3 I'll go for minority attack
was the night doing start with this
bishop takes a six not quite working or
it takes you six also interesting can I
just take twice
hmm
interesting takes takes and like 94
Bishop d3 expected me I'm getting close
to sacking on c6 whoa what is this take
I've rookie three and then I think it's
okay take 643 queen takes you to Brooke
axiom lawn rocky eights queen a3 c3
Quincy won mm-hmm that's close
let's just go for it see what happened
us yeah so this is the line I just said
rook e8 c3 immediately I live Queen d1 I
also have a check Queen D one looks nice
when takes a two I fork otherwise we're
trading Queens
okay am i getting revenge oh there's
rook here I still have to be careful
look there Queenie - probably I take
take uh yeah taking doesn't work
so Queenie to
[Music]
see - I take takes rook see one routine
one rookie one should be okay
twenty-four
I mean King each one way time up a full
rook I'm up a full rook okay some reason
I thought it was just up a minor piece
there's Queen d1
play the smooth oh no I can't play that
move mmm it's still kind of annoying
there's night 94
[Music]
cutting off the bishop I just want to
take let's get rid of this pawn I'm
controlling all these squares so the
Queen can't really defend from behind
rook do you want I can take right oh no
I can't take
I mess up I think I messed up
I could take the rook though let's take
the rook messed up slightly I have this
this move
yeah okay play the sending active King
to activate my King further
I should win the pond now
oh no it's coming from behind
oh my gosh are you serious oh that's
insane
I like I bailed out that's so insane
it's such a good game to what I do I
just killed my addition to the first
move
hmm I killed my other bishop - what am i
doing
okay let's fight back playing fee
karelis
have a closed position very closed as
before before p6
okay
surviving kind of kind of tilting them
if more people can tell me don't tilt
that would be nice
yeah let's do this and prepare to castle
not the most comfortable situation do
this
ha g5
what else to do I mean there's this move
okay
just holding on for dear life all night
a5 coming
try this
tics
I have to take rotate shades
I have a very bad feeling about this
okay I could take
a g5 coming
ah g5 it takes you six my king if I want
to be brave
yeah let's chop show some bravery King
takes g6
I mean I need to keep my pawns like this
to block out the bishop had to prevent
Queen h6 it's probably a good move this
move
the queenside down to my Knight g5
so terrifying takes takes there there
there what else to do
I don't see a move
I take and they could try and take
Richy choose a problem Queeny seven
maybe Queen here move threatening meats
please don't see it take my three nights
three nights free nights yes all I was
getting smashed
it's a early Christmas miracle
someone clip that need to to fight for
clip of the week again okay
oh we enough one okay time to play
quickly and aggressively
oh hi gambit let's gambit okay not sure
the point of that gambit but and develop
with active pieces I could have taken
the pond hmm played this move just one
of my pieces to come into the game
quickly
okay free pawn and the crooks trapped
and night of threes of me threats and a
fork threats Wow with a game how long
was that game that was a very short game
okay that's what I need a couple wins in
a row 10th place
let's go center like g3 is a move kind
of blocks my bishop oh I'm losing a pawn
mmm takes takes
played this move as a seven will be
attacked maybe I shall play left for too
late
okay ideas to do this in queenside
castle or Queen d2 I'm blacking castle -
okay I desperately want my lights read
bishop to come to life this is a move
what is going on
takes takes and then c3 I'm actually
curious about a rule I can't play this
move to mmm I see five coming now this
should be okay
I do you want a castle soon Wow
so black lost casting rights I sack the
pawn or do I play c3 first or did I play
g3 first at four
maybe f4 getting ready for the bishop
explosion let's do this move I'm sacking
b2 I'm attacking the bishop
I played g4 here I will play g4 lift
takes I can take the knight I'm fighting
meet so many people hanging me than one
that's so generous
thanks for clipping that so many people
clipping it man
okay a tenth place or a nine place 30
minutes left
I don't want to do this freaky five
coming if you're I had vision d7 and
then I'll end up queenside castling hmm
play six running to trap the bishop okay
let's play Bishop d6 controlling f4 yeah
let's uh move play this move I'll end up
queenside castling
you improve the rook slightly liking b8
just some quick improvements I want to
do this and then swing the Queen over
maybe throwing this move play this but
the main ideas are attacking threatening
miss let's do this and go for a four a
five a four it's not a six that's okay
I'm Bishop e6 and it's kind of stuck
there but if takes I have to take back
with a pawn not so desirable but okay
the game continues a four-night c1 so we
got seven should probably start with a
four she rigged up seven makes sense
well what does my g8 there's some plan
of this this hey let's do this maybe
I'll sack
I'm attacking the knight all I bring
this night here if takes I probably take
back with Queen rook okay it's about to
be a party on the Queen side most of my
piece is invited I could take on a three
take on c3
not seeing anything so clear it'll play
this move it seems random but I want to
trap the night
after then queen bee 5 again now
threatening Rogoff 6 cuz I'm controlling
g8 ok Knights trapped I have this move
reading meets Knights undefended - and I
reckon maybe come in I'll pause hanging
I could have taken
I think smothered me I was a very nice
position Queens tied down to the night
which is trapped everything's bad for
whites
wait there you go let's go
so many nice meets several games play E
for always playoff 3 mmm play this move
I think I want to play c3 d4 and d5
interesting just leave the tension yeah
you Queen c2 threatening meeting ideas
what are the odds my opponent gets made
at on each seven so many people hanging
me than one what does this opponent was
copying me playing firoozeh very similar
position always play off three I don't
how about nylon coming to e2 a six
expected I'll try and Castle average of
F 2 with Bishop c4 d3 thanks for the
bits DJ yeah
see for a while the c4 I can take and
taking king do you want let's still a
fight a 93 most likely next at 5 juicy
imagine he castles I play e5 and made on
each seven that would be so great I mean
there's some potential to attack each
for why not those positions of a
delicate I should teach six you have
seven their their ID to takes not seeing
it I could take a free pawn there's
ninety five g5 let's do that looks like
fun
g5 right away or maybe this move first
get the access to that file that's a
good move it's like when do you one
defend rook g8 g5 and Queen h5 ideas
later takes okay I have ninety four now
tricky tricky live g3 nights restricted
by my queen I'm queen h5 now maybe p3
ideas chase of Bishop and not a five
ideas too
and also maybe take maybe I'll take and
c4
just block the bishop and rook f1 to
come I'm a nice time advantage bishops
out of play this bishops kind of stuck
but whenever the knight moves I'll have
a five this Bishop also kind of stuck
but doing work a lot of things are stuck
play this move Queenie - rookie - Wendy
- Ricky - yeah I could take maybe no
that's bad mmm not to do that's annoying
move I guess I could just take good
attack the Queen - mmm it's my plan c5
I see a line I'm not sure if it's great
I'm gonna do it let's see five Queen
takes me five takes up six Brooks still
pinned and Bishop f4 threatening h7 oh
no I blended a queen no why do i blender
a queen resign Queens move sideways
forgot about the Queen on c5 look
because looks like Bob Ross let's play
do i play let's play Knight c6 e one
five okay some English maybe six g6
have the double fianchetto now play 96
mile castle so I'm in eighth place
lost my streak 19 minutes left five
looks like normal chests throwing king
each eights f3 expected hmm
oh there's a smooth what's going on play
this move I have night night threats
what's going on here it's Queen minus
six looks reasonable
each fortnight gf7 say rocky eights
mmm I really want to take maybe it's
justifiable
yeah let's justify it I got a pawn to f3
my bishop supports and it's just about
teleporting the Queen's of g2 King G -
I'm not worried about whoa maybe I
should be worried there's h3 that's why
it's gonna have to play h3 just start
simple just leave like kind of being
stuck as yeah the king is completely
stuck and my knight will stay here
forever
h5 ideas everything's stuck like eaten
rook can't even sacrifice itself for the
night I'm controlling all these squares
my White has very few squares to work
with
each horse I could take and taking makes
sense
well there's queen d4 in some line
though for yeah let's just leave White's
to suffer oh there's King h3 I guess
this is what I signed up for at 5-4 also
take let's play 95
yeah White's doing a good job of being
resourceful but White's still stuck
I think the bishop is just trapped in
I'll take on e6 if whatever plays off
three or f4 I take I'll win back
material now I'm running out for a for
discovered check hmm G for F 3 is GG
keen eh - best move
Chuck I mean yeah that's laughs three
bishops now for every stuff I trade
rooks why not hmm
this is funny line
it's what Bishop still stuck
oh there's bishop the exact three but
opponent missed it phew
let's bring the Knight to c4 I'm
blocking out the rook there's no like no
real open files this is the only open
file but it's blocked by the knight
Oriana and standings okay I want to pass
the fine gold monster and maybe Creek or
okay I think I passed fine gold still
kind of far away from Luke are ya
should I beat the car that won game
alright what to play and play chess
let's see four looks fun um I have a
check just play this move threatening to
drop the rook kind of theirs might see
703 bishop bishop was not defended yeah
this move in the 95 Wow 95 chops our
queen what a game
opponent looking for the resign button
you can find it it's right here
Oh can't resign before move 10 or after
oh okay
resigns that's funny so a point was
trying to resign probably but it
wouldn't let them
yeah you can't throw a game like at the
very beginning okay control the center
King is already kind of safe hey
Alexander horse thanks for the bit I'm
gonna try and finish strong let's play
this and it's to fellow upon an e5 DJ
thanks for the bits oh yeah oh yeah
takes one Castle kingside
Queen d1 normal maybe Bishop to you
three to come yeah it's like a French
structure Castle at four ideas such a
depressing Bishop oh this is a move 95
forest
and then this move hmm maybe this move
connect the rooks yeah it's still gonna
take some time what looks very fun want
to do this in this oh i plundered
I just plundered but it's not that bad I
don't think where is it
I was unnecessary
[Music]
let's do this
to do a 5 XA 5 there's still some traps
night before I think I have this move
yeah
I only get the bishop here it's still
some counterplay take sticks should be
ok I do not have one if necessary I'd
see for expected we'll trade
hmmm do this
I should make loops which III probably
preventing Queen h4 I've rook takes b6
now
that's nice Knights attacks
in a certain place
Oh some 94
you'll play play this move I should take
with her rook I'm not gonna have like a
super crushing attack I might have to
trade Queens not what I want really not
what I want then trade nights mmm I'm
not looking so great I do have a nice
Bishop I have to use what I have
oh this move this is nice move I'll win
c4 I didn't I had that move before it
too huh okay can walk the King to d4
it's interesting I'm not going to be
able to take the pawn and play I'll play
this to start takes takes doesn't quite
work and this move that's risky
let's play this still some tricks good
move
ciao in the pond and go for your dirty
flag
ooh free rook nice I like free rooks
okay well the game opponent blundered
the rook yeah still seventh place
oh good game opponents being very nice
okay chestnut it's played e55 okay
pieces develop very naturally f5 and do
this i blundered upon opponent doesn't
take it
[ __ ] weenie seven well I've wondered
more pawns and maybe the exchange
wow what a move okay I'm gonna go crazy
and sack the night
okay I would like to get one more game
in after this to catch up to blue car
could be tough though its first things
first this will win this game I'm
already done a piece but I mean I'm not
really showing so much respect thanks
for the bits people awesome keep it up
appreciate that
yeah I'm down the piece but this piece
doesn't really count on the castle soon
okay
it should be fun to attack I should have
played off for immediately okay I'll do
the slow build up Queen h5 eventually f4
attacking the knight going all out Oh
[Music]
takes takes let's just do this amazing
ideas soon
looking for meat that's close
I see some idea like um takes here here
and then Queen h4 athonite g3 it's very
close
I mean maybe I'll just take back with
pawn that's good enough
no Creek or past me so I have to win in
past week or I was very important to
finish in top eight so I think there
might be like I know there is arena king
point prizes
this should be meet a moment I'll win
the Queen my Queens getting trapped oh
man
okay this is still crushing though let's
okay resigns next game so someplace okay
it's beatable opponents I can't use more
than a minute on the line on my clock
play this move
there's Bishop III but then 97
all right when I pass Lucar I would be
the ultimate village the ultimate
revenge to bukhara is a pass him in the
tournament all comes down to this game a
slow build-up go too slowly though I
could take let's just be solid keep the
bishop I got soccer Brooke it's okay
though not if for ideas g3 I can take
I'll play g6 and then sac on h3 maybe IG
three I take you can't take back cuz me
than two if Rho G one I think I can take
I was looking very good let's go for in
for the kill I need Knight to f3 coming
all of their schoolmates Queen each
three does this work we need three make
should be double-checking takes and then
Knight mates so beautiful I get one more
game in okay one more six place let's go
I'll probably take a draw at some points
G tag things for the bits
okay I pass blue car ultimate revenge
that's already nice position play for
please Susi for risky its castle
I'm B 3 C 4
we have to get to move 20 and then I'll
offer a drama
yeah draw camp offered before move 20 I
mean I have like potential meeting
attack soon well that's like we need to
let's draw do anything it increases
distance from Abu kar who just won it
looks like for Creek or just one yeah
because other people might be taking
draws it's not gonna meet it offer draw
okay
game ends and draw next game but the
tournament is pretty much over
seventy two point finish well the
tournament's won a tournament
congratulations
we were gonna try and lets out 20 moves
and then that's okay
Indian lad congratulations firoozeh I
had an interesting game against Cruz and
then just blundered a queen due to
miscalculation this is my my second best
arena Kings ever this is my best Fisher
random arena Kings over yeah it's been a
while since I finished in top ten this
might be my second time finishing in top
ten so there was at one time I want it
but yeah I feel like I played some
interesting games there are a lot of
opponents giving me made in one Fidel
Corrales gave me made in one they're
like three or four games in a row
opponents just blundering and then there
is this beautiful clip so beautiful and
watch this mmm let's watch it
wait for it wait for it okay
how's nice yeah I lost a blue car like
three times there was at one time I
think I should have drawn heard one and
then he flagged me well done me yeah I I
was tilted I think against fiddling and
he dropped me than one I think that was
at the turning point Thank You
Alexander's horse